au casino de paris
en salle c'est bien vu boon qui fait
mike brant donc à la fin du spectacle
une idée de judo a je crois qu'on peut
le dire très exactement elle le dit
d'ailleurs je le répète lui dit tu vois
je suis très disciplinés moi aussi bien
alors maintenant moi je vous ai connu
donc en voyant ce spectacle au casino de
paris et puis aussi en étudiant votre
dans votre vie votre vrai nom c'est
daniel hamidou et dany boon en fait
c'est le nom d'un héros de séries en
fait non d'un trappeur c'est un copain
qui est daniel boone il s'appelle le
héros rim est quelqu'un qui a existé
d'ailleurs qui était un canadien qui a
traversé l'alaska
voilà à pied ah oui bien donc c'est venu
logiquement alors vous êtes les
armentières un point bas mais fier en
1966 et vous savez le rang
qu'armentières c'est le pays de clc line
renaud la chanson de line renaud sur
sont méconnus ne seriez pas ça
elle a fait des trucs grave aussi les
grenats votre père vient de kabylie est
arrivée en france à ces jeunes était
boxeur il a eu quelques victoires
d'ailleurs sur le ring à alger a marqué
sa vie en faisant de la boxe en faisant
de la boxe et puis un jour il a
raccroché les gants et il a pris le
volant d'un 3 tonnes d'un 38 3 tonnes
c'est par un camion s'est même pas le
poids d'une voiture
trois gros coup qui connaît on a trente
mille tonnes en tonnes
je n'ai pas le permis en même temps moi
comme j'ai dit voilà donc voilà donc un
jour il raccroche les gants il prend les
commandes d'un gros camion disons au
panache et tous les matins il va faire
le plein de super dans une
station-service keizo al de gasoil
et il vaut mieux le réseau la télé tu tu
as fais pas max meynier jusque et
transporte bien donc tout cas l'arrière
il ya une sorte de grande cabine c'est
pas un appartement d'accord les mardis
des marchandises et donc tous les matins
il va faire le plein de gasoil dans la
station service des parents de votre
mère voilà et un jour votre mère se
retrouve enceinte parce que derrière il
ya aussi ya une couchette
par contre le maire se retrouve enceinte
elle a 17 ans et 8 36 oui son
commentaire s'est excusé ouais et vos
grands-parents coupe les vivres donc ça
va être sérieux qu'ils ont été obligés
d'habiter dans le camion au moment
oui oui c'est vrai qu'ils avaient invité
d'un oui parce que mes grands parents
s'ils n'ont pas supporté l'idée way que
ma mère soit enceinte surtout d'un
étranger c'est un drame
tu pars donc elle est partie dans le
camion
c'est mes arrière grands parents qui ont
aidé mais c'est sympa ça je savais pas
oui oui oui c'est sympa je ne savais pas
du tout alors votre maire bah oui elle
est obligée de faire des ménages parce
que c'est compliqué il ya en plus de
petits frères qui arrive et puis un jour
il décide d'acheter cette fameuse maison
mais en deux corps ont à crédit c'est
vrai parce qu'on va voir la fin là je on
va voir comment c'est l'histoire de la
maison se termine c'est pour ça que je
dis ça c'est une chute bien enfance très
dure pour vous là on rigole mais bon
enfance très dure père très sévère
relations conflictuelles ça se
traduisait comment le ceinturon mobilité
boxeur il se mariait les heures sup
les clercs du talent
layton enfants dany boon assez
introverti
à l'époque oui à ces deux récits
d'ailleurs presque autiste et vous
quitter le foyer familial vaches de 15
16 ans oui oui c'est 5 à 15 ans alors
bas dans cette enfance évidemment vous
de puiser de quoi faire ce que vous
faites aujourd'hui c'est une sorte de
thérapie en fait
en fait jean gervais beaucoup j'ai été
très introverti je parlais pas
énormément je regardais les gens quoi et
je veux y aller copain de mon père où
est donc oui et puis j'ai observé quoi
oui une galerie de personnages dans
votre spectacle et votre mère alors y
avait un truc c'est qu'elle raconter des
choses horribles en se tordant de rire
oui donc effectivement vous puisque vous
faites fi nalement wheels adjoint mais
quoi et les gens étaient atterrés elle
est la règle il bien ouais elle tournait
en dérision les journées tout en
dérision
alors l'histoire voilà j'en arrive à
l'histoire de la maison parce que c'est
pas innocent ils vont divorcer un peu
comme les parents de marie gillain
je suis devenu un spécialiste mannequin
et vous vos parents divorcent après 25
ans et ils ont vendu cette maison il est
passé leur vie à la payer cette maison
il l'a vendu pour cent mille balles
magix pourquoi votre mère raconte rsa
sûrement mais c'est un peu dur elle est
là tout le monde serait mardi gras sauf
l'oie non mais bon 25 ans de boulot et
puis puissant mille balles oui mais non
mais par enfin mon père était très
très heureux de son métier ils aiment et
ce qu'ils faisaient donc voilà il gagne
pas beaucoup d'argent mais ça allait oui
alors votre père qu'il n'a pas connu
votre succès est décédé avant c'est
simple dommage parce que début il avait
du mal à accepter ou facile ça oui il
avait dû y avait du mal à accepter que
je fasse il voulait pas dire non il
disait il m'a bien fait recteur équipés
dès la semaine prochaine non c'est vrai
pour lui c'était pas possible car non
prévue une location assez assez précoce
un très jeune à l'école vous alors ses
membres ce qu'il allait se coucher dany
boon
évidemment elle n'a pas droit de
regarder le film à la télé mais que vous
avez beaucoup d'imagination le lendemain
la cantine et raconter le film qui avait
pas vus oui j'allais à la cantine je
voyais juste un bout de film et
j'inventais la fin et je montais la
suite du film
j'ai raconté ça mes copains et toujours
pareil était justement très extraverti à
l'extérieur à l'école way you lie du
mime dans votre chambre paréage est
autiste de variétés ces très beaux lots
j'ai complexé emballé à part mes
oreilles ou terriblement comme vous
d'ailleurs un petit peu mais ça m'a un
peu passé oui c'est vrai je veux plus
l'on peut les j'ai eu les cheveux assez
long on voit moins oui et là vous faites
un truc que j'ai parlé avec votre
coiffeur la réprouve vous faites une ré
comme ça je sais pas vous voulez que je
fasse d'autre
ben je sais pas il m'a dit oui piscine
glisséo mm bien sûr je veux une autre
idée même avec judith quand on le
regardera talent et pas ici mais ça
c'est pas souvent c'est que de jouer
avec vous aussi vous regardons 17
pourquoi vous ne tentez pas une autre
notre coupe de cheveux hpc si je faisais
l'arrêt de l'autre côté ça irait non
padre un truc un peu un peu fouillis
simple
alors je peux pas moi donc pourtant vous
dormirez qu'un élastique autour des
oreilles c'est ma mère qui m'a donné ce
complexe et quand j'étais bébé elle me
trouvais très très beau souffle les
oreilles décollées donc elle me mettait
un élastique il sorte de bonnet comme ça
qui me reconnaît les oreilles et elle
enlevait le matin sa dette ou avez vous
eu jeudi gti dit j'étais beau de trois
quarts avec la tête légèrement penchée
comme ça voilà ce que vous voyez pas que
j'avais les oreilles décollées avait un
beau regard et visite à un moment vous
quittez la maison fait du mime dans la
rue gagné 7 cents balles et pour vous
c'est énorme comme parce que votre père
et pour vous c'est une grosse somme
oh oui c'est ça surtout que j'avais dans
la tête qu'il fallait que je fasse soit
la sncf où un concours gens pètent et
sncf où ma mère me répéter ça en pleure
tout le temps voir la fiche de paie qu'à
la fin du mois mais c'est pas écrit la
poste
et donc est donc effectivement d'un seul
coup j'ai été embauché pour faire du mot
tomates dans une grande surface et j'ai
eu un cachet le soir c'est 700 francs à
lui signalé fraîchement galérait quand
même parce qu'à une fois j'ai vu là vous
jouiez dans des espèces de bruit il
fallait déplacer le baby foot pour
pouvoir pour pouvoir jouer quoi pour
fabriquer une espèce de seine s'est
jamais au téléphone quelqu'un qui me dit
ouais jacente culturel mineurs et
j'étais allé chez lui et je suis tombé
dans un bistrot et
jeudi mais ya pas de scène il dit baby
au bourget le baby tu joues à la place
j'ai dit mais n'y a pas d'éclairage nice
atépa année on s'est salués mais bon et
je le soir arrive et je me suis dit tant
pis je vais jouer je suis envie de faire
ça c'est mon rêve quoi j'avais 16-17 ans
et je donc je reviens le soir il y avait
donc la salle bourrée donc quatre
spectateurs raid bourré au comptoir
options et chanter des as vraiment
bourré et je suis rentré sur scène en me
disant je vous ai tiré deux coups de feu
y avait un revolver un blanc pour les
faire taire pour pouvoir pour qu'ils
m'écoutent j'ai tiré deux coups de feu
ils se sont tus et qui vont me regarder
comme ça et à ce moment là le berger
allemand du patron que j'avais pas vu
qui était derrière le comptoir le saute
dessus en croyant que j'attaquais c'est
vrai tout ça est vrai qu'il ya une
bouffe la jambe le le patron de direct
flexiloop polkowice pour voler les clés
mais quatre spectateurs
mort de rire piccola il arrache le chien
de mon genou
il arrache mon genou pour chiens
repart en coulisse vous recherchez en
coulisses en cuisine ce qui est des
cuisines des registres
je cherche un os de poulet pour
remplacer ma rotule sa femme me fais un
pansement à la mayonnaise et y revient
samedi après midi j'ai munch à dole brac
quart temps dit il faut les rigolos j'ai
dû retourner sur scène il y en a un des
quatre qui m'a dit au milieu du
spectacle m'a dit monsieur y joue plus
alors voilà c'est tout c'est tout le
talent dont vous avez hérité de bodmer
ça c'est raconter des trucs thériault en
une grande maison ça aurait été
évidemment des frais après je me disais
je vois là bas on arrive maintenant à la
fin parce qu'un jour vous rencontrer
thierry jolly le frère de sylvie joly si
vous avez vos premiers succès dont la
déprime qui est votre sketch est le plus
petit et le plus connu à l'époque
maintenant c'est passé vous faites
toujours je me souviens pas donc voilà
les olim non je vais bien ouais c'est ça